foreign
expert on friendship I'm up against a
lot because of
um the hierarchy that a lot of our
cultures place on love right with
familial love at the top with romantic
love at the top and with platonic love
friendship love really at the bottom and
with so many countries people feeling so
lonely and so disconnected I believe
that if we leave friendship at the
bottom of this hierarchy it's like
there's gold at our feet that we're
treating as concrete and so why are
friendships so key
well our bodies have always known that
we need an entire Community to feel
whole and just being around a spouse for
example only surfaces one side of
ourselves so maybe the part of me that
likes to Garden or do yoga will begin to
wither away if my spouse for example
doesn't like these activities but then
when I'm around a friend I can guard it
and plant my pothos with them and I'm
going to write another friend that I can
downward facing dog with and I feel my
entire identity a coordinate accordion
outward unfold and fan out and I
experience the full richness and
complexities of who I am when I have an
entire Community to bring that out in me
and so that's one of the reasons why
friendship is really important but I
think there's two reasons why we tend to
really devalue it
one reason is because we just don't know
how to make friends so luckily I'm going
to help you with that a little bit today
but the other reason has to do with
something I like to call the Paradox of
people
that on the one hand we need people they
make us feel healthy they make us feel
connected they make us feel like our
very selves right but on the other hand
people are really scary they can dismiss
us they can reject us they can actively
harm us and so this sort of dilemma that
we Face the the sort of entity that we
need the most is also the entity that
can harm us the most and how we walk
across this tightrope handling this
Paradox of people says a lot about our
ability to make and keep friends because
if we find ourselves stuck in the place
where we see people as Miss as we
mistrust people where we see people as
potentially rejecting us and harming us
it's really hard to Foster connection
and this really materialized for me one
day when I had bought an apartment and I
was really excited to make friends with
my neighbors because I'm like oh my gosh
I'm going to be here for a while and I
see a couple of my neighbors in the
hallway when I'm walking home into my
apartment with my ex at the time who's
living with me and I walk right past
them right because Paradox of people I'm
scared of them they might reject me they
might see me as weird if I try to
introduce myself so I Scurry into my
apartment and my ex he pushes me back
into the hallway to talk to my neighbors
and says to me you know you're writing
this book on Friends what would you tell
other people who are in your situation
and so as I'm sort of stumbling back
into the hallway I'm thinking about a
few things that I have learned through
studying friendship so intensely and so
two observations that I have on
friendship and two takeaways for what we
can do to make and keep friends first
observation friendship does not happen
organically in adulthood right and in
fact one study found that people that
think that it happens based on luck are
actually lonely or five years later
whereas people that see it as happening
based on effort are less lonely five
years later so what did that tell me
that if I was just there hoping that my
friend my neighbors would someday try to
be my friend it probably wouldn't happen
right and so I would need to make that
effort in in order to be able to make
friends but second observation that I
have based on reading all the research
on friendship is something called the
liking gap which is a phenomenon wherein
when strangers interact and predict How
likely the other person is to like them
they underestimate how much the other
person likes them so this research
really suggests that we're less likely
to be rejected than we think
which leads me to my first takeaway for
making friends if you want to make
friends you have to assume that people
like you right the reason is when
researchers told people hey you're going
to go into this group and based on your
personality profile we predict that you
will be liked this is completely bogus a
total lie but they found that when
people went into this group of people
they became warmer open more friendly
because they made this assumption and so
indeed it became this self-fulfilling
prophecy called the acceptance prophecy
that when we assume will be liked we
make it more likely that we actually
will be liked whereas other research
finds that people that tend to assume
that they're rejected even when the
circumstance is ambiguous like my friend
maybe they're just like hungry or
something rather than that they hate me
right those people that go straight to
maybe they don't like me they actually
become cold they actually become
withdrawn and they reject people and
then they get rejected in return so I'm
thinking of these things in the hallway
you know right by my neighbors I'm
thinking that you know I can't wait for
this happen organically okay I'm afraid
they're gonna reject me but that's less
likely to happen than I actually think
I'm thinking I should assume that
they're gonna like me and then one last
thing I have to remind myself of was to
overcome something called covert
avoidance which is our tendency to show
up around other people physically but
check out mentally right like you're
like hanging out with people and you're
on your phone or that would look like me
just standing in the hallway hoping that
my neighbors talk to me and so to make
friends you have to overcome covert
avoidance by not just showing up I
showed up in that hallway right but you
also have to engage with people when you
get there so I ended up approaching my
neighbors and saying hi and Marissa I
just moved into 103. it's really great
to meet you
can we start chatting
and at some point you know I asked them
like is there a group where we can keep
in touch
um I'd love to you know chat further and
they tell me about their cat group that
they have for cat parents in the Drew
and I don't have a cat but like I'll
take connection when I can find it so
the cat group became half cat group half
social group and I think sometimes we
think that you know a tiny act something
small like saying hello can't have
colossal consequences for our life but
when we can lean into the sort of
positive side of the Paradox of people
when we can initiate and assume People
Like Us right it can have colossal
consequences because since I said that
hello me and my neighbors we met up and
we hung out every Friday socially
distance of the pandemic in the garden
behind our apartment right
and so I think that this experience
really taught me the importance that
while we all face this Paradox of people
while we all face this dilemma that if
we want to make friends if we want to
connect with people we have to be able
to move away from the part of ourselves
that is fearful that is mistrustful that
assumes people will harm or reject us
and turn towards the part of ourselves
that simply wants to love and connect
with people and can ready ourselves to
engage in these new connections with
optimism and with hope you know my niece
read my book platonic and one thing that
she took away from it was that for
friendship to happen someone has to be
brave so be brave
thank you thank you
I like all of that and I could see in
the chat that um a lot of the members
also really loved some of the things you
shared uh there so thank you so much for
for that wonderful talk and for those
tips which we will dive into in this
conversation and you know I think just
to sort of start uh your line of work is
just so interesting friendship is is it
seems such a unique area to research and
I actually want to read something back
to you from your book to help us
understand a little bit more about just
the importance of of this type of
relationship
um you say friendship in releasing the
relationship pressure valve infuses us
with joy like no other relationship
without needing to plan for retirement
fulfill each other's sexual needs and
work out who should be scrubbing the
shower Grime we are free to make
friendship territories of pleasure so
can you talk a little bit more about
this and just why friendship holds such
an important role in all of our lives
yeah yeah well first of all I'll take a
step back and say like clearly
connection is so Central to all of us
um you know the research finds that for
example loneliness is more toxic for
your body than having a poor diet or not
exercising right and and these are
things that we talk about in the public
health conscious but we don't talk about
social connection enough maybe for our
UK folks you all have a prime minister
of loneliness so it's a it's a little
bit different right
um but when we talk about the impact of
loneliness there's actually three
different dimensions of loneliness there
is intimate loneliness which is the
desire for someone to be very intimate
with there's also relational loneliness
which is the desire for someone that
feels as close to us as a friend might
and then there's Collective loneliness
which means I desire to be part of a
group working towards a common goal and
this research on loneliness really
suggests that
just like I said we really do need an
entire Community to feel whole because
if we just focus on being very nuclear
you know just having a spouse and that
being the center of all of our
connections right that's maybe touching
on our intimate loneliness but not our
relational not our Collective right and
so I think a lot of us found this in the
pandemic that you know we maybe have
been home with a spouse or partner that
we've really loved a lot but we still
ended up feeling lonely and that's
because like as social species as social
creatures like we just need an entire
Community to fulfill us you can touch on
this a little bit in the talk
um and in the book you separate
sort of the way you think about
friendship and to two categories you
talk about you know sort of a backward
look at how we've traditionally
experienced friendship and then you look
forward at how we could build better
relationships um better platonic
relationships and so if we could just
talk a little bit about sort of that
first um section just diving into how we
as a culture tend to think about
friendship and how does this really
impact the way that we actually approach
it
yeah so I'm reading all the research on
friendship and what sort of materializes
before my eyes is that our personalities
are fundamentally a reflection of our
experiences of connection or
disconnection right like in some ways
our personalities our coping mechanisms
from the experiences of connection or
disconnection we've received so whether
you are friendly open warm vulnerable
trusting cynical aggressive even violent
all of this is predicted by what your
history of connection or lack thereof
looks like so how we've connected really
affects who we are but not only that who
we are really affects how we connect
right those people that have that
history of healthy relationships they
have an internal set of beliefs within
them that allows them to continue to
facilitate healthy relationships this is
if people are familiar with attachment
Theory securely attached people who
think others can be trusted who think
they can be vulnerable who think they
can turn to people for support right and
they go into new relationships with the
set of beliefs and allows them to
continue to create these new
relationships whereas people who have
had difficult previous relationships
those can be internalized as a belief
system that then can impede their
ability to Foster further connections
right because they may think people are
going to reject me that I can't be
vulnerable that I can never feel safe
around anybody even when someone is safe
they're still holding that assumption in
that judgment right and so what I wanted
platonic to do because I know some
people hear this and they're like good
for those people with healthy childhoods
you know whatever for me I guess I do
absolutely not your work is focused
specifically on adult friendships which
for a lot of the reasons you've already
outlined seem like are just really
challenging for us to develop but I
guess can you talk about sort of why
this breakdown happens and really when
we start to see that it becomes more
difficult for people to to make friends
in the same way as you do when you were
kids yeah so when I say friendship
doesn't happen organically in adulthood
I don't mean that friendship doesn't
happen organically in childhood because
for children it often does and they have
certain ingredients in their environment
that
really Foster friendship so Rebecca G
Adams she's a sociologist and she says
you know for friendship to be fostered
you need to have organically you need to
have this repeated unplanned interaction
and the shared vulnerability right and
so in school we have that we have that
through our lunch period we have that
through our gym we have that through our
recess right we're seeing our friends
we've seen people every day we're
letting our guard down we end up sort of
just developing these friendships but
when you think about adults going into
the working worlds
um you may have repeated unplanned
interaction with your colleagues less so
now that we're going more hybrid and
remote workplace right but we're often
not as vulnerable in the workplace and
that's why one study and this again this
is caveat U.S context one study found
that the more time people spend together
at work the less close that they feel
and so we need to recognize that as
adults we don't have the same
infrastructure we had as kids so we
can't rely on the same set of
assumptions that oh this is just going
to happen I don't have to try I don't
have to initiate because as I shared
from that previous research study if we
think that way for a lot of us it won't
happen
I mean and I think also just thinking
about
um what friendship brings to the table
for you what it um what it actually how
it benefits you you have this phrase in
your book where you say connecting
others makes us ourselves and it's about
much more than just the pleasure and of
connection there can you explain a
little bit about that yeah so Harry
stack Sullivan he's a psychiatrist and
he has this Theory called the theory of
Chums which is basically that our Chums
are our friends earlier in life they
provide us with the sort of relationship
template that we take on into our future
so it allows us to continue to connect
throughout life right and and there is
some research that finds that if we
connect in childhood we have good
friends in childhood we have higher
self-esteem and adulthood we're more
empathic in adulthood right and so he
kind of argues that the therapy
experience is similar to
um the chumship experience in that with
your friends you share things that you
feel like you should be ashamed of right
and when you are ashamed of something
you're not integrating it into your
entire personality you're trying to push
it away and suppress it and not make it
who you are and the shame can really
take over your whole personality because
you're pushing away this part of who you
are that you think is shameful but then
so much of your personality is spent
focusing on making sure nobody finds out
this thing right and so that's why shame
can be so um encompassing and enveloping
but what stack Sullivan argues is that
when kids share this shame with their
friends and their friends are like you
know we still love you you know this
isn't a big deal for us right and we
still think you're amazing and we accept
that about you right we begin to be able
to accept it in ourselves and and to
bring whatever we felt shame about to
see it as just part of our personalities
rather than antithetical to the
personality that we want to have and we
are able to sort of relinquish all of
the energies that we spend trying to
push this thing away and so in that way
these experience of experiencing that
platonic love from our friends
especially at that time in childhood
teenagers where we were very high in
shape we're like highest in shame than
throughout the whole throughout our
whole lifespan right that our friends
are there at that time when we're so
high in shame to help us integrate that
and to help us connect to all sides of
ourselves so that we sort of be tend to
become who we fully are it's just so
interesting how much vulnerability and
shame play into this and in a way it
seems like on the one hand as you get
more confident you start to lose some of
the ability to to um to to make new
friends but also
um using that confidence leaning into it
to actually make the friends is what you
you need
um so it's fascinating
um well I want to dive into some of the
member questions we're receiving because
they're they're also really interesting
so Ted member Arnaldo they ask married
people often complain about lack of time
to cultivate friendships outside of the
marital Circle what insights have you
gained in your research about about the
effect of outside friendships in a
couple's relationship ooh I love this
question
I think that having outside friendships
is necessary for having a healthy
marriage I do and this is where I'm
coming from with that the research
basically finds that if I make a friend
I'm not only less depressed but my
spouse is too it also finds that when
you get into conflict with your spouse
it negatively impacts your release of a
stress hormone cortisol right but if you
have quality connection outside of that
marriage that doesn't happen your
cortisol release is normal right other
research that finds that particularly
for women who tend to have more close
Intimate Relationships when they go
through difficulties within that
partnership they are more resilient to
it when they have this outside support
right and so it's just like if I can
access this other person to Center me
during times of stress in my marriage I
can return to that marriage in a
centered and grounded way and that's a
resource for me and it's a resource for
my spouse where we see that people that
only have that close connection with
their spouse
they have high rates of what's called
concordance which means that however
your spouse feels is kind of how you
feel
um they're they're sort of energy
affects you a lot more when they're the
only person that you're looking to for
support and so what happens is like the
natural Ebbs and flows that could happen
in a marriage they're so much more
impacted and there's so much more
devastated during those times of Ebbs
because they don't have that support
outside of the relationship so I think
sometimes we see we think of like oh are
my friends a threat to my spouse my
spouse is spending time with their
friends they're not spending time with
me but if we understand more broadly the
importance of friendship and how it
makes every other relationship in our
life better we will see that there's
actually Synergy between these
relationships that my friend having a my
spouse having friends outside of this
relationship is what makes them a better
spouse for me so so much of it has to do
with the way we just think about the
role friendships play in our life
um well we have lots of questions that
are coming in about uh sort of the steps
to actually making friends
um and I think before we get into some
of the those specific questions I know
you in in the talk you sort of shared
you started with two tips this idea of
first assuming that people like you um
and then overcoming what you call covert
avoidance or that urge to sort of
mentally check out when you're meeting
someone new
um what are some of the other ways that
you you recommend people
um try to build use uh tools excuse me
that people use to build new friendships
yeah so I could walk through my own
experience of making a bunch of friends
and share this in a story I went to
Mexico City alone and was there for 10
days and was like okay if I spend 10
days here and don't make any friends I'm
going to be very lonely so how did I
make friends when I was there
first I went to a coffee shop I heard
another American there and I knew you
know he's less likely to reject me than
I think I also knew the research on
transitioners right people that are in
times of transition are most open to
Friendship so people that are traveling
people that have just moved to the city
people that have just started school
people that have just retired right
those are the people to try to connect
with versus you know
um someone who's been here for a while
and already has an established Network
so I knew this guy's a transitioner and
he's less likely to reject me than I
think so I'm going to engage with him
and I I ask you know where are you from
like I'm from the US too we start
chatting and I end up inviting him to a
meet-up that night and it's like a
language exchange Meetup and that that
language exchange Meetup I mean someone
else who's cool and I say
um you know do you want to come to this
Lucha Libre wrestling match with me then
he said yes and I think you know what I
realized too from the research on
friendship I used to think that making
friends was about
being interesting being smart being
insightful being charismatic being
entertaining but in fact people report
that this entertainment factor is the
least important quality they look for in
a friend and the most important quality
that they look for is someone who makes
them feel like they matter so for me if
I want to connect with someone it's not
about me trying to impress them it's
about me trying to make them feel valued
and you know say hello to them and
engage with them and tell them what I
like about them and tell them what I
appreciate about them right like you
know there's a study that looked at um
friendship budding friendship groups for
like 12 weeks which of these pairs ended
up becoming friends and it was the ones
that shared the most affirmation and
affection towards each other right and
so it's it and just to go even deeper
into the research Rabbit Hole there's a
theory called risk regulation Theory
which indicates that we decide how much
to invest in a relationship based on our
view of How likely we are to get
rejected so when we show people I like
you we're telling them hey you're not
not going to get rejected if you try to
be friends with me and that makes people
really want to feel safe really feel
safe connecting with us right so so I
was both engaging with these people and
I was trying to make them feel loved and
tell them how great I thought they were
and how happy I am to meet them as I
reached out to them and then I went to
my Spanish class
which if you don't have any friends what
I recommend is that you join something
that's repeated over time and remember I
said repeated unplanned interaction
shared vulnerability is that
infrastructure that kids have for
friends that we lack as adults so as
adults we really need to recreate that
infrastructure and so if you join like a
social group that's repeated over time
turn your hobby into a community right
that's a really important way to make
friends so for me it's I want to take
the Spanish class because I love
learning languages for you it might be
football team improv team hiking team
meditation group but it's just finding
something finding a group that meets
around this hobby because when you find
something that's repeated over time what
happens is something called the mere
exposure effect sets in the mere
exposure effect describes our tendency
to unconsciously completely
unconsciously like people just because
they are familiar to us so for example
this researcher found that when he
planted women into a large psychology
lecture at the end of the semester none
of the students remembered the woman but
they reported liking the woman who
showed up to the most classes 20 percent
more than the woman that didn't show up
for any right nobody remembered her but
they liked her a lot because they had
seen our face like this is our brain
right and what I think the other
implication of mere exposure effect is
in the beginning mere exposure effect
hasn't set in so it's going to be
awkward it's going to be weary you're
going to feel uncomfortable right maybe
a little distrusting that's not a sign
that you need to stop showing up that's
a sign you need to keep showing up
because when you continue to show up
they're gonna like you more you're going
to like them more right so I joined that
Spanish class that was repeated over
time every day in Spanish class I would
ask people to go out to lunch with me
we'd go out to lunch together then we
went to Lucha Libre together you know of
course I was only there for 10 days so
there's only I can only go so deep with
with folks but but in general when you
join the event that's repeated over time
you want to start generating exclusivity
with someone in that group exclusivity
means you develop memories and you
develop experiences with one person in
the group that you don't have with other
people so pick whoever in the group that
you really liked
um and ask them oh would you be open to
like getting coffee before getting tea
like before or after our next group like
I love to hang out and and those are
like the budding stems of friendship and
luckily if you're in this group right
you don't have to put in as much effort
and then you had your tea and now you're
going to just continue to see them over
time and you have the wheel start moving
for friendship and connection so Ted
members Celia actually is curious about
virtual friendships and sort of how all
this plays into it especially to some of
the points you're making earlier about
the pandemic
um you know for people who have met on
social media only as opposed to in real
life they ask is it possible to have a
strong virtual friendship how important
is in-person connection or getting
together in real life
yeah so this is such a nuanced question
in some ways right because it's it's
such a both and
um we know from the research that
in-person connections tend to be
stronger than virtual connections right
but I think that that research it
doesn't account for certain communities
like people with disabilities people
with severe social anxiety
um even older older people that aren't
as mobile who tend to find connections
online
and even though you know the online
connections tend to not be as deep as in
person they can get deep if you're
practicing the same skills that you
could practice an offline connection to
establish deeper relationships so for
example like the research finds that if
you're just passively scrolling on
social media Doom scrolling it makes you
more lonely it negatively impacts your
mental health and well-being but if you
are engaging actively on social media
I'm posting I'm commenting on something
that you shared I'm saying
congratulations to you that's actually
linked to less loneliness us and is
something that actually makes us feel
more satisfied in our relationship so if
we want to have deep virtual connections
it's certainly possible but we have to
bring those same principles that we use
in offline connections to create more
intimacy like things like being
vulnerable with someone
um being generous with them or showing
affection towards them that also works
online they feel like they like one
another more but When You're vulnerable
with someone who's avoidantly attached
that doesn't necessarily happen the
avoidantly attached person doesn't like
you more because you're vulnerable
because they have this all their own
wounds around vulnerability right
they've learned that it's not good to be
vulnerable I shouldn't be vulnerable
like that's the implicit message that
they have that really inhibits their
ability to connect so what the
implications of this I think is that If
You're vulnerable and it doesn't go well
and it wasn't from a place of fear
remember that it's not always your fault
that other people have their own issues
that they're dealing with which may lead
them to respond to your vulnerability
negatively and that doesn't mean that
you did anything wrong I mean I think if
you continue to try to be vulnerable
with this person who's who's shown you
that they can't handle it then I think
you should you should try to Pivot right
but just because someone responded
dismissingly to your vulnerability it
might mean that they have their own
issues to work out well you know I think
in sort of thinking about how to make
friendships work well or to be really
good at this the the process of doing
this there's a popular excerpt from your
book
um that you showed in the Atlantic where
you talked about the concept of Super
Friends so what makes someone a super
friend and how how can we all strive to
be Super Friends yeah secure friends AKA
Super Friends these people are secure
with themselves which means that they
don't have to try to use other people as
a tool to fulfill their sense of self or
to help them Escape threatening emotions
or feelings so they're able to really
humanize other people fully and the
research on to securely attached people
find and again these are the people that
have a history of healthy relationships
but there's also earned secure which
means you've might not have had a
history of healthy relationships but
you've done the work on yourself to to
develop a sense of security right so
remember this isn't this isn't nobody's
doomed by their attachment style but
what qualities do we see in them they
are more likely to initiate friendships
they're more likely to maintain
friendships they're less likely to
dissolve friendships they're more
generous towards other people because
again they fully humanize other people
like insecurely attached people they
sometimes perceive other people through
the lens of their own wounds right so
anxiously attacks people it's like you
need to prove to me that you value me
and you love me because I'm so afraid
that you're gonna abandon me and then I
can try to control you and make you do
this this and this to show me that you
really really love me right and so
they're not fully humanizing another
person because they're almost seeing
that person as a tool to fulfill their
sense of self avoid avoidingly attached
people they just think everybody's out
to harm them and that everybody's sort
of untrustworthy so they almost see
other people as threats so they don't
fully humanize them people for the their
beauty and um the the sort of resources
that connecting with another person can
bring you
um but these securely attach people they
tend to assume other people like them I
talked about something called pronoia
which is the opposite of paranoia it's
the idea that you know the universe is
commiserating for your success and for
your well-being and that you can trust
people they're comfortable with
vulnerability they're more empathic
they're comfortable sharing their needs
but also fulfilling the needs of other
people they're more responsive to the
needs of other people when they engage
in Conflict it's all about perspective
taking they're not like you do this and
otherwise I'm going to be pissed off
they're like these are my needs what are
your needs let's figure out a way to
collaborate and figure out something
that will work for both of us so they
tend to be quite healing friends they
tend to be I talked about avoidant being
low effort low reward anxious is high
effort low reward secure is high effort
High reward when it comes to friendship
and then what about friendships that
where there's not necessarily a
difference in value but maybe a distance
whether that's a physical distance has
been created or some sort of emotional
distance
um because your life has changed in some
way how do you suggest people go about
maintaining and nurturing those types of
relationships
so there's research on long distance
friends that finds that we are helped
when we perceive our friendships as
flexible Not Fragile so when we perceive
that oh I haven't talked to this person
in a few months I I'm gonna assume that
friendship's asleep not that it's dead
so that I can reconvene this friendship
at any time right so it's being able to
recognize that our friendships ebb and
flow and when we're at an ebb that
doesn't mean okay I'm never going to
contact this person again because the
Friendship is officially over right we
assume that this ebb is part of the
normal process to to flow again so that
facilitates us being able to re-engage
in the Friendship at any time so Whitney
basically this all goes back to I really
think this tip right it's so it's such a
it's such an all-encompassing tip right
because what I'm basically telling you
is to assume people like you right like
when you're free you don't talk to your
friend a while assume that they're still
interested in being friends with you
again this isn't about
um you know being delusional if
someone's clearly indicating that
they're not interested in a friendship
with you then move on but if it's
ambiguous and you're like I'm not really
sure we haven't talked for a while but
they haven't necessarily rejected me or
they still are responsive when I reach
out to them you want to make that your
running assumption in response to
ambiguity because again having that
assumption really facilitates continued
connection
[Music]